[Music]
Disney's animated Lion King will always
hold a special place in people's hearts
but the 2019 version takes the
opportunity to correct some of the crazy
plot holes goofs and mistakes fans have
spotted over the years in the original
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers I'm Jon and
in this video I'm explaining how the
Lion King remake fixes many of those
issues from the 90s classic some
spoilers ahead so take care if you
haven't seen it yet don't forget my Lion
King giveaway is still running so be
sure to subscribe and leave a comment
about the movie for your chance to win
the animated lion King's opening scene
and circle of life Tsonga iconic moments
that the remake mostly reproduces
shot-for-shot however it also fixes a
few crucial errors from the 1994 movie
just before Simba's presentation
Rafiki anoints him breaking open a fruit
to release a red liquid which he paints
on the young cubs forehead before
dusting his face to dry the mark the
fruit that Rafiki brings with him
appears to come from the ancient bay a
Bab tree that he lives in and the
problem with the original scene is that
a bear bad fruit doesn't contain a red
liquid and is actually dry inside with
white pulp and large seeds in the new
movie the film makers have fix this by
having Rafiki use some red roots which
release a red dust when he breaks them
it's also this red powder that makes
little Simba sneeze rather than Rafiki
dousing the poor little cub in a handful
of dust as he did in the animation the
2019 movie also changes the hand that
Rafiki uses to anoint Simba from his
left hand to his right this is
consistent with the fact that Rafiki is
right-handed when he's fighting the
hyenas with his stick later in both
movies
Rafiki himself was misrepresented in the
original movie as although he's modeled
after a mandrill in the film and the
screenplay he's referred to as a baboon
some of the Disney animators even
thought of him as a mutated monkey and
gave him physical features such as a
long tail which is incorrect for a
mandrill it means you're a baboon and
I'm not I think you're a little confused
on that baboon reference has been
eliminated from the new movie and
rafiki's design has also been corrected
by replacing the long tail he had in the
animation with a short stub that's
biologically accurate for his species
another mistake corrected in the new
Lion King is the color of
Simba's eyes in reality newborn lion
cubs start life with blue grey eyes then
after two or three months they turn an
orange brown color
the remake reflects this as you can see
young Simba has dark bluish eyes at the
time of his presentation and once he's
grown up a little they're a darker
yellow a orange color
in the animation as a newborn cub Simba
simply has dark eyes and when he's older
his eyes or a brownie color and to make
us connect with the characters and their
feelings even more the original
animators gave the Lions eyes of very
like humans so they have a pupil and
iris and a white of their eyes which is
sometimes colored yellow even though
real-life lions don't have whites in
their eyes
scars bright green eyes have also
changed for a better sense of realism in
the reboot the original movie was also
guilty of featuring numerous wild
animals that aren't native to the film's
African setting for example when Simba
sings I just can't wait to be king
various animals construct a crazy Tower
and on the very top or a group of giant
anteaters giant anteaters are only
native to Central and South America and
so wouldn't be seen in the wild in
Africa so this time around the
filmmakers have made sure there's no
giant anteaters in the movie other non
African animals that were also scrubbed
from the latest film include the tail
hanging monkeys that make an appearance
during I just can't wait to be king and
the Gopher that pops up during Suzy's
morning reports also hit the cutting
room floor in the remake for the same
reason yes sir knows from the
underground one mistake which has been
left in the new version is the inclusion
of leaf cutter ants these appear in the
opening sequence in both movies even
though they are only native to the
Americas
I think they kept these misplaced ants
in the film for two reasons first of all
the filmmakers wanted to keep the circle
of life sequence more or less
shot-for-shot and secondly the ants play
a special part later in Rafiki
discovering that Simba is still alive
the animated movie often emphasizes how
dim-witted the hyenas are Zazu you told
me they're nothing but slobbering mangy
stupid poachers ixnay on the upbeats day
would stay but this doesn't reflect the
fact that in real life hyenas are
intelligent skilled and dangerous
predators which is why Shenzi who's
voiced by Black Panthers Florence
kizomba is a lot more menacing in the
new version you're much faster you are
dying with your king now and although
the hyenas are still antagonists in the
remake the Nazi goose-stepping scene has
been cut to fit the new films more
realistic and grounded approach hardcore
Lion King fans may have noticed a small
change in the new movie when Simba and
Nala are reunited in the original film
as they rub their heads together you can
also hear them pairing much like a pet
cat does however in the remake Simba and
Nala sparing has been removed likely
because animal experts believe that
lions either don't pair at all or the
noises they make a technically different
the pair of a domestic cat following
Simba and Nala Sri Union is can you feel
the love tonight which the original
filmmakers described as perhaps the most
steamy love scene in any Disney film
during the song Nala gives Simba what
the filmmakers have called a come-hither
look in the new film however that moment
is replaced with Nala giving Simba and
affection at lick which fits with the
remakes much more realistic depiction of
animal behavior in the 1994 movie Rafiq
he discovers that simbra is still alive
after the lion flops down on some plants
and the earth and leaves which scatter
are magically carried by the wind all
the way to the wise monkeys tree where
he reads the leaves in an empty tortoise
shell the new movie has a quite
ingenious and perhaps more feasible
method for Rafiki to discover the truth
about Simba this time a tuft of Simba's
fur falls off and goes on a complex
journey floating on the wind than a
river before being eaten with some
leaves by a giraffe and ending up in a
ball of dung that a beetle rolls along
that ball falls down a hill and breaks
apart releasing the tuft of hair which a
leaf cutter ant then collects and
marches up the tree of life where Rafiki
spots it and recognizes it as Simba's
firm it's a nice little updated sequence
which also fits with the film's circle
of life theme in the first movie there's
a curious goof in the scene where Simba
and
visit the elephant graveyard I wonder if
it's brains are still in there there's
only one way to know come on let's go
check it out the young lion cubs are
ambushed by the hyenas who emerge from
the skull of a dead elephant however
fans have commented that when you look
more closely at the proportions of the
skull its grotesquely large and far too
big when compared to real-life elephant
skulls which is why the 2019 movie skips
over the hyenas coming out of the skulls
and instead they meet Simba and Nala
inside a cave another problem fixed from
the animated circle of life sequence is
Rafiki seemingly impossible ascent to
Pride Rock
from the front if you look at the shape
of Pride Rock and how it juts out it
would be extremely difficult for Rafiki
to climb up beneath it I'm very silly
too given he could access the rock fire
a much easier route instead the new
movie fixes this by showing Rafiki
walking onto the top fire a much more
gently sloping rock face as you can see
the new Lion King tends to tone down
some of the animations more exaggerated
cartoony moments to better fit the photo
realism of the new CG version is not a
lion it's a furry bird look I going let
me get a closer look
so the remake changes this moment where
Timon lifts Simba's pour up all the way
above his head in an incredible feat of
strength for a tiny little meerkat
instead the new movie has Timon
identifying Simba as a lion by looking
at his teeth it's a lion it gets bigger
another scene made more realistic this
time around is when knowledge chases
Pumbaa in the original movie the warthog
rather foolishly tries to escape her by
squeezing through a gap under a tree
root that's too small for him how bleak
is fat which is why it doesn't happen
like that in the new story and instead
Pumbaa is cornered by Nala when he slips
and falls trying to run up a moss
covered Rock another small but important
change which diehard Lion King fans may
have noticed is it after scar is
defeated and symbol table and O'Ree make
Zazu says your majesty it's a nice fix
to the 1994 ending where Zazu says these
words to Simba although the actual audio
ended up cut from the final film if you
watch the animated scene closely you'll
see Sal zoom mouthed the words of Simba
walks past but the dialogue can't be
heard that mistake was introduced
because the filmmakers thought a moment
of silence would add more gravitas to
the scene however they didn't redo the
animation to stop Suzie's mouth moving
speaking of adding things to the film
the new movie also adds some new meta
moments and Disney Easter eggs and the
Timon and Pumbaa scenes and I talked all
about that in my Lion King comparison
video tap the screen to watch that or
click the link in the video description
now did you spot any new plot holes or
mistakes in the Lion King remake let me
know in the comments below and subscribe
to enter the giveaway congratulations to
the winner of my spider-man giveaway
contact me via email for my about page
so I can send you your prize tapleft for
my next Lion King video or tap write for
another Disney video or something else
you're sure to like and if you enjoyed
this a like and a share always hugely
appreciated thanks for watching and see
you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers